19h bonsoir bienvenue à la à la maison
soirée photo ce soir non pas un retour
de voyage quoique c'est une soirée photo
familiale vous savez lorsqu'on se plonge
dans les archives qu'on ouvre les boîtes
un peu poussiéreuses et qu'on se dit
mais c'est qui ça et elle date de quand
cette photo et avant de vous présenter
notre invité je vous présente évidemment
Bertrand Guyard bonjour bonsoir Bertrand
journaliste sculptures aux filles je
sais que vous adorez ça vous les photos
d'antan comme ça moi j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup la grande chanson
française donc ça m'amène et même le
grand cinéma français donc ça m'amène
souvent vers le passé mais vous me
faites la transition pour présenter
celle qui va nous ouvrir sa boîte au
trésor ce soir il y a quelques pépites
je vous assure c'est France Brel bonsoir
bonsoir merci Bertrand merci d'avoir
accepté notre notre invitation fille de
Jacques Brel évidemment alors vous avez
compilé dans ce très beau livre je le
montre je l'ai ici et puis on peut le
montrer sur notre écran Jacques Brel
chronique d'une vie Jacquie alors il y a
des photos il y a des archives et puis
surtout à votre récit le récit personnel
ce que vous en retirez finalement de
l'enfance de votre père oui mais alors
on est bien d'accord que quand le livre
commence en 1909 je ne suis pas né donc
je ne peux pas dire que je sois
totalement témoin Jacques Brel non plus
n'est pas net non plus effectivement
puisque 1909 c'est l'année où mon
grand-père le père de Jacques prend un
bateau au port d'Anvers et il part vers
le Congo car il va avoir une vie
coloniale au Congo jusque dans les
années 20 pourquoi je parle de mes
grands-parents parce qu'il me semble
essentiel quand on a envie de rencontrer
un personnage de connaître les parents
qu'on le veuille ou non nous héritons de
certaines choses et quand dans les
livres suivants puisqu'il y en aura
d'autres ah oui ça c'est vous m'avez
bien prévenu ça c'est Jacky c'est
l'enfance mais alors il y en a d'autres
qui vont venir il y en a d'autres qui
vont venir absolument et donc quand je
dirais d'une phrase et il a hérité de
ceci ou de cela de son père ou de sa
mère il faut savoir de quoi on parle et
je crois que déjà qu'en fait alors
n'allons pas trop loin parce qu'il est
aussi je pense Jacques à un moment
sociologique très important dans
l'histoire culturelle dans l'histoire de
la chanson française mais c'est surtout
le fils de son père et de sa mère il va
hériter de son père le sens est
responsabilités la ponctualité et
surtout vous aussi vous avez hérité vous
êtes arrivés bien malheur il se fait que
j'ai arrêté de mon père l'envoyé ça
remontant et alors de sa mère mon père
va hériter de la joie de vivre de
l'envie de chanter de l'envie de faire
des fêtes et d'aimer les êtres humains
alors c'est peut-être un peu un peu
basique n'importe quel psychanalyse
dirait la même chose mais est-ce que on
vous plongeant dans l'enfance de votre
père vous sentez les prémices de ce
qu'il va devenir de ce qu'il a chanté
ensuite et bien alors imaginons avec
tout ce que je viens de vous dire je
viens de vous dire que Jacques est un
travailleur et la sens des
responsabilité il a assumé on peut le
dire au niveau du Tour de champ c'est
quelqu'un qui donnait trois fois par
jour de temps en temps son tour de chant
il a assumé tous ces rendez-vous
merci oui
ça n'a rien à voir avec le travail donc
pourquoi mon père vomitait ben c'est
parce qu'il avait un table parce qu'il
faut bien remettre les choses en
perspective mon père n'a fait aucun
travail préalable pour devenir chanteur
d'accord puisque mon père n'a jamais
voulu être chanteur mais n'allons pas
trop vite parce que cela on le
développera dans les prochains ouvrages
exactement bon Bertrand je vous laisse
la parole vous avez des questions pour
prendre je le sais c'est un voyage ce
livre c'est on va le voir des superbes
photos que vous avez vous avez parlé de
tout ça mais c'est aussi vous faites un
effort extraordinaire de rédaction qui a
un sens c'est-à-dire que chaque chapitre
correspond à des verts ou un titre de
chanson par exemple quand on parle du
père de votre grand-père de Romain c'est
Romain Brel vous dites il y a la
moustache du père donc on va expliquer
un peu à tous les gens qui ne sont pas
comme qui connaissent pas toutes les
chansons de Brel Parker pourquoi il y a
la moustache du père ça veut tout dire
ça te dirait beaucoup de choses de la
psychanalyse quand même bon ben écoutez
alors on reste ce soir en psychanalyse
d'accord que sur l'intention de la
moustache de mon grand-père je peux pas
vous dire grand-chose à part que c'était
à la mode dans les années 20 porter la
moustache mais la moustache du père et
donc effectivement un verre de Jacques
dans la chanson ces gens-là et il parle
de la moustache du père et dans le cadre
et le cadre en bois il y a la moustache
du père bravo bah vous avez gagné le
premier round alors attention attention
il faut il faut essayer de récupérer ça
donc Jacques parle de cette moustache du
père dans une chanson parce que ce père
en fait en question n'est pas du tout le
sien d'accord mais dans la chanson on va
le comprendre plus tard dans la
généalogie puisque je parle et de la
famille de mon père et de la pardon et
de la famille de mon grand-père et de la
famille de ma grand-mère il faut savoir
que ma grand-mère était orpheline à
l'âge de 3 ans et je peux imaginer que
dans la cuisine ou la salle à manger de
chez ma grand-mère quand elle est petite
il y a un cadre avec un homme et une
moustache et ce qu'admerveilleux avec
Brel c'est que tout le monde se dit
c'est la moustache du père et que je
reprends cet extrait et tout le monde
pense au père mais il s'agit de son
grand-père à lui qu'il n'a jamais connu
et qui était en fait le père de sa mère
alors pourquoi est-ce que dans la parole
dans la chanson on peut préciser
Bertrand est dans ce cadre en bois il y
a la moustache du père qui est mort
d'une glissade et qui regarde son
troupeau bouffer la soupe froide donc ce
père il n'est pas là en fait il est dans
ce cadre en bois il ne l'a jamais vu il
ne l'a jamais vu c'est son grand-père et
qu'il est mort d'une glissade je peux
éventuellement le comprendre parce que
il est mort très jeune bon etc mais j'en
parle dans le livre et encore une fois
je pense que c'est essentiel parce que
s'il dit cela ça veut dire que ce
portrait cette moustache se moque se
manque ça c'est un mot très important
pour mon père toute sa vie il créer sur
ce qui va lui manquer et ce qui manque
c'est au démarrage des grands-parents et
mon père n'a jamais eu de grands-parents
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il va après
écrire une chanson sur grand-père et sur
grand-mère Bertrand alors il paraît
qu'il est plus fort que moi alors après
après
votre mère on en parlera puisque c'est
le grand amour dont il parle aussi dans
cette chanson et quand même c'est grâce
à elle qui a gardé toutes ces parce que
c'est ça là on va parler on voit toutes
ces photos
tous les gens vont pouvoir voir les
photos faire des formidables photos
regardez celle-là ça c'était votre maman
qui avait conservé ça qu'elle avait reçu
ça de votre grand-mère alors racontez un
petit peu ce que on revient c'est un
travail de décryptage de de psychanalyse
et en même temps d'historienne alors oui
parce que parce que Brel il est il
arrive à une époque et il est riche de
tout cette histoire la qu'on avait vu
avant c'était donc les
Chelsea donc il s'agit la dame ici en
arrière-plan enfin premier plan voyez
bien qu'elle est en noir sont tout en
noir d'ailleurs parce qu'elle est veuve
et les veuves le monsieur calvissé avec
sa moustache et donc là il y a 4 filles
mais il faut savoir que il y avait en
plus deux autres fils qui sont déjà
morts aussi donc c'est vraiment et c'est
rond de famille qui vont de morts en
mort voilà les ronds de famille qui vont
de mort en mode et donc en fait elles
sont toutes en deuil ma grand-mère et
juste au-dessus de mon
arrière-grand-mère d'accord il y a
quelque chose à mon avis qui est quand
même relativement important Jacques dans
ses chansons est un être sensuel c'est
un être qui aime bien ressentir les
choses tous les sens sont exacerbés et
toutes ces femmes qui sont là sont des
couturières et il serait intéressant de
regarder dans les chansons de Jacques
toutes les additions au tissu le satin
velours la dentelle et donc voyez
l'école qu'elles ont brodé c'est
elle-même qui ont au brodé ça et donc
mon père est attiré par les femmes qui
font de la couture
il y a quelque chose qui m'interroge à
chaque fois quand vous parlez vous dites
Jack vous dites Brel et vous dites pas
mon père ou papa et bien je vais vous
expliquer alors c'est pas de la
psychanalyse c'est de l'obéissance c'est
à dire je m'explique c'est-à-dire que
quand nous avons enfin quand Jacques m'a
demandé de partir en mer avec lui pour
faire le tour du monde pendant trois ans
qui n'a duré que six mois jusqu'à Fort
de France
nous étions sur le bateau en train de
préparer à envers le bateau pour le
grand départ et je lui pose une question
et je l'interpelle en disant tiens papa
où se trouve la tenaille qu'importe je
le vois encore se redresser me regarder
et me dire tu vas quand même pas
m'appeler papa tout le temps
donc merci de m'appeler Jacques j'ai
entendu une interview aussi où il dit il
parle on lui dit vous vous dites pisser
je crois et il dit je vais quand même
pas dire faire pipi c'est c'est enfantin
il n'aime pas ça l'enfance pourtant
c'est le journaliste qui lui dit parce
que quand même c'est vulgaire et j'ai
accélère du tout ce qui est vulgaire
c'est un monsieur qui va avoir qui va
trouver le jeune homme qui va épouser
une fille en disant combien votre fils
gagne par mois enfin bref donc c'est pas
c'est pas ça mais là il dit non c'est
pas possible que tu m'appelles papa et
donc il m'a demandé de l'appeler Jacques
et donc chaque fois je l'appelle Jacques
c'est je lui obéis c'est lui qui me l'a
demandé c'est quoi l'enfance de votre
père c'est quel milieu alors ma
grand-mère vient d'un milieu ouvrier mon
grand-père industriel qui s'est fait
tout seul travailleur acharné les
affaires le cours de la bourse il faut
faire fortune il fait fortune d'où la
phrase mon père se chercheur d'or
l'ennui c'est qu'il en a trouvé et donc
Jacques Jacques est dans ce milieu là
alors l'enfance de mon père c'est quoi
c'est un enfant hyper gâté par sa mère
il peut faire ce qu'il veut c'est le
petit c'est le petit attends il faut
comprendre
c'est le chouchou de sa mère mais
Jacques on dirait maintenant un
hyperkénétique il tient pas en place
c'est un pitre il n'aime pas obéir et il
lui faut tout le temps du mouvement et
en fait l'enfance de mon père c'est
qu'il se pose énormément de questions
parce qu'il regarde les adultes et il se
dit un jour je vais devoir devenir comme
ça et là c'est plutôt la crise
d'angoisse en disant j'y arriverai
jamais j'y arriverai jamais à faire tout
le temps la même chose à faire ceci à il
voit les jeux ils voient l'hypocrisie
sociale il se dit que les gens en fait
font des phrases pour ne rien dire et il
se dit pourquoi les adultes ont oublié
comment ils quand ils étaient enfants et
donc il est malheureux mais dans notre
côté passent son temps à rire faire le
pitre et donc cette espèce de globalité
des deux fait que c'est quelqu'un de pas
comme les autres Bertrand non mais moi
je continue les photos
il y a beaucoup de photos il a l'air
très heureux on le voit avec des
bouquets de fleurs on le voit très
beaucoup et on n'a pas toutes les photos
mais avec le vélo il est il est scooter
un peu et on le voit souvent très
heureux c’est-à-dire que danser dans ses
chansons après va revenir de façon un
peu
nostalgique dans son enfance parfois ça
va on va avoir un trait un peu pas noir
mais un peu peur obscur mais là on le
voit là voilà il y a son frère et il y a
son cousin c'est ça absolument
commentez-nous une photo cette joie
qu'on voit mais oui parce qu'il est
heureux d'abord on voit que la voiture
donc ils sont en randonnée donc il est
content donc il est pas à la maison en
train de regarder la pluie qui tombe
derrière la vit dans la cuisine où il
fait sortir des grilles donc il est
heureux il bouge il adore la nature
Jacques ne supporte pas la ville il aime
bien quand sa bouche et là il vient de
certainement de raconter une blague
Jacques aimer rire c'est évident qu'il
aimerait mais pas que ça et donc là il
est dans un jour de fête c'est
merveilleux mais il fait le pire
regardez ces deux pieds j'ai à quand
même se déguiser il aime raconter des
blagues je suis persuadée que c'est lui
qui met l'ambiance à ce moment-là parce
qu'il a une dizaine d'années de moins
que les fasse cette entre 5 et disent
que beaucoup à l'époque hein oui oui
mais il tient tout à fait sa place et sa
mère est là donc qui font couple avec sa
mère je dirais donc c'est peut-être sa
mère qui prend la photo et qui rigole
aussi donc sa mère c'est la joie de
vivre et donc quand ils sont ensemble
c'est la joie de vivre et puis les beaux
quand il est gosse alors qu'après il
sera pas content de son physique ça
c'est vous qui le dites ouais c'est ce
que je pense mais je pense que lui il a
aucun problème avec son physique
à force d'entendre des gens qui vous
disent tiens tu es pas beau tiens il y a
ceci tiens tu as vu ta gueule le type il
commence à se poser des questions mais
lui il sait jamais posé toutes ces
questions il écrit des timide mais les
timide ça n'a rien à voir avec un
physique c'est un comportement intérieur
si vous voulez dire que mon père se
prenait pour une ganache non
nous sommes en direct quelle heure
est-il il est 19h14 nous sommes avec
France Brel fille de Jacques Brel qui
nous présente ce livre Jacky sur
l'enfance de de son père alors l'enfance
de Jacques Brel dites-moi j'ai écouté
beaucoup d'interviews de votre père
il parle avec cette voix d'adulte
évidemment ça doit être très puissante
qu'on connaît tous
il parle comme un enfant quoi le rêve
constamment il parle du rêve quand
j'étais petit je voulais être tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps tout
le temps l'enfance oui parce que pour
lui c'est essentiel parce que il n'a
jamais voulu devenir un adulte et pour
lui l'enfance et l'adolescence parce que
dans l'adolescence est-ce que tu es
rebelle il y a ce côté sensible il y a
ce regard que l'on pose sur les les
êtres et les situations mais mon père
après l'adolescence il s'est dit je ne
veux pas devenir adulte d'autant plus
que ses parents étant relativement
âgés il avait plutôt l'impression que
c'était des grands-parents plutôt que
des parents et bien évidemment avec le
temps mais ils ont eu un petit peu moins
d'énergie ils sont devenus vieux il faut
savoir que mon père à partir de l'âge de
30 ans signait toutes ces lettres et
cartes postales le vieux oui ah donc là
tout de suite passer un cap c'est comme
s'il regrettait
plus que l'enfance
le sens de l'enfance en fait
c'est pas qu'il regrette il regrette
rien du tout il a toujours envie de dire
ce qu'il occupe depuis l'enfance
imaginons pour vous Thibault que vous
soyez dans une vous vivez quelque chose
d'exceptionnel vous dites ça jamais je
l'oublierai et vous en parler à tout le
monde et ça en Kikine tout le monde
parce que vous revenez toujours avec la
même chose et vous reparlez de ça que ce
soit l'enfance ou que ce soit le début
de l'âge adulte qu'importe mais il y a
des moments vous dites moi pour moi
c'est ça la vie c'était ça ça a duré un
mois c'était merveilleux tout était
extraordinaire et c'est ça que je
voudrais rechercher sans cesse ben bref
il fait la même chose mais avec des
rêves d'enfants il a envie d'être pilote
il a envie d'être Vasco de Gama mais à
chaque fois il réalise ses rêves
exactement et c'est pour ça qu'il dit le
talent d'avoir l'envie de faire quelque
chose et quand il est devenu chanteur
c'est parce qu'il avait envie de le
devenir qui là à qui ce talent parce
qu'encore une fois il a jamais pris
aucun cours de chant et donc cette
espèce de volonté de vouloir concrétiser
ça c'est vrai je vois ce que vous voulez
dire c'est vrai quand on demande à un
enfant tu veux faire quoi dans la vie et
c'est des choses simples pompiers
chanteurs que sais-je c'est ce qu'il a
fait en fait à la mais oui c'est ce
qu'il a fait il a arrêté il a arrêté et
toutes l'énergie qu'il avait c'était
pour réaliser ce qu'il avait en lui mais
il y a pas de nostalgie il y a pas de
regret c'est son présent et ça c'est une
force extraordinaire Bertrand cette
photo elle nous a fait réagir de la même
manière hein
évidemment
nous on connaît brêle on connaît pas
brêle comme vous donc on connaît brêle à
travers
ses chansons et des fantasmes de ses
chansons tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué
parce que de gamma quand on perd quand
on pense à votre père on pense à Don
Quichotte qu'on le veuille ou non même
s'il est pas dans Quichotte et là quand
on pense à cette chanson on a pensé on a
repris je vous ai apporté les bonbons
parce que les fleurs c'est périssables
c'est terrible l'image
du personnage qui est vous parlez de
Jacky et en été c'est ça qui est
formidable dans ce bouquin c'est qu'on
revient sur l'homme mais ce qu'il a été
et plus fort pas plus fort à une
influence même sur son passé absolument
alors bon moi bon en fait ce bien avec
Brest et qu'on peut faire des tests
psychologiques comme ça avec tout le
monde donc vous c'est les bonbons ok
c'est merveilleux j'aurais dû la portée
de Bruxelles là je suis désolé mais en
fait il faut savoir que cette photo est
le pendant d'une autre photo où c'est sa
mère dans la même position avec les
mêmes fleurs et les fleurs seront
toujours le lien entre Jacques et sa
mère la maison l'appartement qu'occupait
ma grand-mère donc la famille il y avait
toujours des fleurs partout elle adorait
les fleurs et j'en parle énormément dans
le bouquin je l'ai je fais des je décris
des scènes où je dis que elle gamine
cueille des fleurs parce que pour elle
les fleurs c'est juste un peu elle avait
pas d'argent il y avait pas d'argent à
maison c'était difficile mais au moins
les fleurs qu'elle pouvait cueillir dans
le parc environnant pour mettre un peu
de gaieté de couleur à la maison et donc
les fleurs et quand on arrivera au
Marquises on va s'apercevoir que les
témoignages des personnes c'est et il
adorait les fleurs et il avait envie
d'en planter partout et c'est ça et
c'est le lien à la mer c'est la
tendresse d'une mère ces fleurs 19h 18
nous sommes en direct vous réagissez
évidemment sur Le Figaro.fr sur Youtube
aussi je salue Isabelle cadeau qui nous
dit c'est son ressenti qui a fait de
Jacques Brel un grand chanteur peut-être
cette manière vous nous avez parlé tout
à l'heure quelque chose de très
charnelle et ça va dans le sens de ce
que nous dit cadeau un truc de l'enfance
aussi les copains
c'est on pense à ses copains la cour de
récré alors Jacques Brel c'est les
copains tout le temps jusqu'au bout et
je pense à l'aventure c'est l'aventure
c'est le film évidemment où je le vois
briller alors avec les copains ah les
copains c'est indispensable et les
copains c'est c'est ça sa première et
son unique réponse à sa peur de la
solitude Jacques ne supporte pas la
solitude sauf de temps en temps sauf de
temps en temps et il y a un merveilleux
témoignage de Raymond Devos d'ailleurs
qui dit moi je suis vibrer en tournée et
de temps en temps il avait envie d'être
seul au fond d'une boîte de nuit
sinistre et passait une heure ou deux
devant un vieux whisky chaud et et alors
Devos dit après mais qu'est-ce que tu
fais là c'est quoi qu'est-ce que ça
t'apporte tout le monde s'emmerde quoi
et il fait comme ça je touche le fond
et donc Brel a besoin de toucher le fond
de la solitude pour se réveiller le
lendemain et mieux aimé encore les êtres
humains et donc Jacques je vous parlais
du manque tout à l'heure en insistant
sur ce mot il y a un manque dans sa vie
et qui est un manque de tendresse et ce
manque de tendresse c'est la tendresse
qu'il a reçu pendant l'enfance de sa
mère et c'est plus possible évidemment
il le dit on peut plus retourner dans le
ventre de sa mère c'est fini et il y a
une blessure là et cette blessure c'est
les copains c'est l'amitié voilà et
c'est et je voudrais un petit peu réagir
à ce que la personne vous a donné comme
témoignage je pense qu'il y a des
ressentis de sensualité de présence
d'oralité on pourra en parler pendant
des heures mais surtout je pense qu'il y
a chez cet homme un mystère
et ce mystère il est totalement
inexplicable et ce n'est pas parce que
j'ai commencé à écrire des livres dont
le premier s'appelle Jacky que je vais
résoudre ce mystère loin de moi quelle
horreur quelle horreur de découvrir des
choses derrière un mystère mais de le
laisser planer et que Brel encore
maintenant non pas à travers cette
textes de chansons et ses
interprétations nous livrent quelque
chose de personnel parce que c'est sa
Brel vous avez votre brêle j'ai le mien
vous avez un vrai le plus personnel que
le nôtre oui mais je veux dire qu'au
niveau du ressenti le ressenti des êtres
humains c'est la même chose et c'est ça
qui est merveilleux avec Brel il
réveille des choses en nous par ses
chansons et ce mystère est toujours là
et c'est hallucinant de se dire que
voilà il y a plus de 40 ans qu'il est
décédé ayant encore une vibration et ça
ça c'est merveilleux Bertrand
en place et alors là tout à l'heure il
ment magiquement quand même bref parce
que il dit dans rosa rosam qu'il a des
tunnels qu'il a des héros qui n'est pas
bonne qu'il est un con encore c'est pas
tout à fait vrai là aussi vous avez
retrouvé dans Jacky vous montrer
certains bulletins d'école où il a des
disparus et surtout
jusqu'à l'adolescence il est souvent
premier en rédaction premier en français
1er en poésie
racontez-nous un petit peu un instant je
vais vous laisser répondre mais je vais
demander à rien Becker qui en régie de
nous la mettre en plein écran cette
photo et puis chez vous essayez de
trouver où est Jacques Brel parce que
c'est pas forcément très simple et puis
après on me donne la réponse je vous
laisse la parole qui est très clair
quand même mais je le dirai après s'ils
ont trouvé et donc on en était où à la
sur son niveau à l'école le niveau à
l'école c'est très simple donc de tout
ce qui est primaire il y a absolument
aucun problème mais qui quand il rentre
là en première secondaire mais c'est
tout autre chose et et ça l'intéresse
pas il s'ennuie mais le Français oui
toujours toujours toujours
premier en français et sur l'exagération
mais ça moi je dis toujours que Brel est
un Belge marseillais parce que il a le
talent le talent d'exagérer les choses
mais ça fait partie de son outrance et
de ses excès et mais le collège de La
Muse absolument pas absolument pas
Jacques Brel est donc en haut à gauche
sur cette photo vous le voyez c'est le
deuxième et qu'est-ce qu'on voit il
regarde ailleurs c'est le seul qui
regarde d'ailleurs et ça je trouve que
c'est merveilleux c'est merveilleux
c'est le seul qui regarde ailleurs et
donc toujours le regard dans autre chose
je continue avec ce parallèle avec
l'enfance puisque c'est ce que vous nous
proposez dans ce livre Jacky première
partie de la vie de Jacques Brel
finalement vu et revu par sa fille la
critique ah ça c'était difficile pour
lui donc il était très susceptible face
à la critique et est-ce que ça c'est pas
aussi une attitude d'enfants de pas être
capable de prendre du recul comme ça de
voir la critique et de pas se dire bon
qu'est-ce que j'en ai à faire je suis
une super star de la chanson Oh ce petit
journaliste ce petit gratte papier comme
Bertrand Guyard qui est gratuit
qu'est-ce que j'en ai à faire non mais
je pense qu'il est vraiment pas le seul
je pense que c'est tout à fait normal
des artistes qui sont sensibles et qui
créent quelque chose et que quand la
critique n'est pas
chaleureuse mais ça blesse profondément
je trouve que c'est plutôt bon signe
quand tu as l'authenticité de quelqu'un
alors prendre du recul est-ce que c'est
vraiment
un tout petit surtout pour le cinéma
pour quelques films ont été des très
critiqués oui mais c'est oui il était
très blessé d'ailleurs c'est c'est pour
ça aussi que j'ai à la Fondation décidé
de réaliser des films le
même le Far West et le deuxième qu'il a
réalisé
a été très très très mal accueilli c'est
un échec c'était un échec et du coup
qu'est-ce qu'il s'est dit c'est fini je
veux plus ça fait trop mal il y a des
gens qui ont eu confiance en moi et puis
voilà et puis c'est comme ça et je peux
pas recommencer cela donc l'échec est
très très important et pourtant l'échec
il va le connaître toute sa vie comme
tout le monde mais il a connu des échecs
et beaucoup de réussite puisqu'on est
encore là pour en parler je suis
d'accord mais dans une vie on retient
quoi les échecs ou bien les réussites
c'est quoi une réussite la réussite
c'est un grand moment de vanité où on a
l'impression qu'il y a un souffle qui
veut envahit et ça dure quoi c'est ce
sont des paillettes alors que alors
qu'un échec est constructeur et c'est la
raison pour laquelle pour moi c'était
important de finir le livre ici le
premier sur un échec parce que mon père
a toujours eu
merveilleuse vision de tous ces échecs
et c'est l'échec qui construit c'est pas
le succès qui construit ça c'est un
leurre Bertrand cette photo vous pouvez
peut-être j'ai une photo mais je vais
parler de cette photo pourquoi le Google
le bouquin vous l'avez pas appelé du
temps que je m'appelais Jacky c'est une
plaisanterie parce que c'était vous avez
fait ça pour tous les chapitres je lui
répondent comme Brel dans le Brel parle
parce que Jacky c'est plus
courtes
pour tous les titres de chapitres parce
que
tous les intertitres viennent d'une
chanson je suis d'accord mais parce que
je pense
que c'est important comment comment on
nous appelle parce que tout le monde
l'appelle Jacky à ce moment-là il y a
personne qui l'appelle Jacques et
ensuite les gens l'appelleront encore
Jacky ou plus à Paris c'est quand il
arrive à Paris qu'on ne l'appelle plus
Jacky et donc et alors ce qui était très
intéressant encore une fois il s'agit
des autres livres mais je réponds
volontiers à la question c'est que il va
donc continuer à s'appeler Jacky il
arrive ici en 53 et au mois d'août 53 il
est déjà installé dans un hôtel ici à la
gare du Nord et il écrit à ma mère en
disant ça y est j'ai terminé la chanson
qui s'intitule grand Jacques et le grand
Jas qu'on voit dans les colonnes dans
les articles et tout c'est lui-même qui
trouve le titre de Grand Jacques et être
appelé être nommé être reconnu sous
différents termes c'est très important
le nom est quelque chose de fondamental
dans la construction d'une personnalité
et je m'adresse à deux psychanalystes
bien connue
qui connaissent le sujet mais c'est très
important c'est lui-même qui s'appelle
le grand Jacques et ça c'est rare c'est
rare que des artistes arrivent à se
nommer eux-mêmes avec justement cette
capacité à se doubler je reviens à cette
photo parce que là on le voit d'une
certaine manière alors il le faisait
déjà sur scène il était très acteur sur
scène il a cette fibre en lui là
expliquez-nous il fait du thé au collège
il s'ennuie mais au collège il va
rencontrer un professeur qui va se dire
il y a quelque chose chez Jacques et le
professeur en question j'en parle dans
le livre et donc un abbé à l'époque qui
est donc le professeur principal dans la
classe et pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a une
relation qui se noue c'est parce que un
jour au cours de maths Jacques écrit un
texte qui s'intitule la mer alors je
passais des tailles mais dans ce texte
la mère que je publie il y a plein de
mots qu'on va retrouver plus tard et
notamment dans Amsterdam de vous dire
que il y a des marins qui chantent des
chansons etc dans son texte de la
mer et donc ce professeur qui sent qu'il
y a une fibre et qui voit ce texte fait
waouh c'est pas mauvais truffe
d'orthographe mais il dit quand même il
y a quelque chose et Jacques pendant là
pendant la guerre ils s'ennuie et il dit
Oh monsieur voilà c'est la guerre on
s'ennuie est-ce qu'on pourrait pas faire
quelque chose et est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire une dramatique est-ce qu'on
pourrait interpréter des pièces et c'est
lui avec un copain le copain c'est celui
qui est derrière et qui fait une petite
mou donc il s'appelle Robert et avec
Robert Jacques va trouver le professeur
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord le gars
dit laissez-moi trois jours pour
réfléchir il faut quand même sérieux et
très adulte et c'est oui et ils vont
faire des tas de pièces alors j'aime
beaucoup cette photo parce que cette
photo on a très souvent imaginé que Brel
jouait les trois mousquetaires il n'en
est rien en fait il s'agit d'une pièce
de Vendée qui s'appelle Yvonnick et
redresseur de sort déjà un peu donc qui
chute mais pourquoi est-ce que tout le
monde pensait que c'était le
mousquetaires parce que bon à l'époque
il y avait pas d'argent les seuls
costumes qui avaient c'était des
mousquetaires et donc on a tous déguisé
en mousquetaire pour pouvoir faire cette
pièce de théâtre voilà on leur voit à
notre perruque là où ce sont ses cheveux
non non c'est une pauvre c'est pas que
au collège à l'époque on pouvait venir
avec des cheveux comme ça mais
l'anecdote que vous ne savez pas c'est
qu'il est tellement heureux ça c'est
bien passé ils sont là ils ont beaucoup
de succès c'est que Robert le petit du
milieu témoignera toujours en disant ce
jour-là il était tellement sur un nuage
il a refusé d'enlever son costume et il
est rentré chez lui en tram habillé
comme ça je suis obligé d'avancer un
petit peu parce qu'ensuite cette
carrière à Paris donc vous avez parlé on
l'appelle plus Jacky à ce moment-là
il s'est détourné de son enfance à ce
moment-là de sa vie d'avant est-ce qu'il
a mis un point final à son enfant ou
est-ce qu'il y a toujours des liens il
revient régulièrement c'est toujours là
ou non c'est ma vie de belge maintenant
j'ai ma vie de parisien finalement c'est
derrière moi pas du tout donc aucune
coupure c'est lui qui est belge qui
vient à Paris et il reste belge jusqu'au
bout jusqu'au bout et donc il vient
parce qu'il a envie d'écrire des textes
qui lui et il va devoir un peu s'adapter
au début c'est pas facile parce qu'il
est le Belge il a un accent belge
épouvantable et il découvre un monde
qu'il ne connaît absolument pas mais la
Belgique c'est son encre c'est son il y
a l'enfant c'est la Belgique et c'est
très difficile très difficile pour lui
de faire la différence entre l'enfant
c'est la Belgique c'est pareil pour lui
mais c'est pareil pour vous deux aussi
votre enfant c'est un lieu votre enfant
c'est une terre c'est un paysage c'est
lié et et lui il a ça très très fort
alors pourquoi parce que on peut
expliquer
plus tard il est marié à votre mère il a
des enfants il s'en va complètement il
vit plus avec vous finalement pas du
tout il s'en va pas du tout complètement
ah bon mais non il s'en va mais en fait
il arrête pas d'écrire de téléphone et
de revenir c'est justement la raison
pour laquelle je souhaite continuer à
écrire pour expliquer tout ça c'est pas
du tout quelqu'un qui n'est pas ma mère
ils se sont morts
c'était convenu comme ça mais Jacques va
rentrer tous les mois à Bruxelles voir
ses copains retrouver les amis et il va
rentrer à Bruxelles parce qu'il a besoin
de ça pour parce que parce que la France
est pas facile et je dis bien la France
parce que la France elle est tournée et
puis Paris et c'est la France et Paris
c'est totalement opposé à son enfant
donc il revient mais ne coupe pas
Bertrand
non mais là on va sur notre boîte
troubadour c'est qu'on quitte on quitte
un peu l'enfance
Jacques Brel est devenu Jacques Brel on
se basant sur ce que nous raconte la
première personne c'est vrai que depuis
on va dire une dizaine d'années on
revient sur sur la psy enfin tu vois sur
l'origine psychanalytique des chansons
de Brel chose qui n'était pas pas dites
il y a de ça on va dire 30 ou 40 ans
c'est à comprendre les chansons de brêle
pour ce qu'elles étaient ça de grandes
chansons des grandes histoires des
voyages des voyages rapides ce qui est
formidable dans votre bouquin c'est
qu'au fond vous donne vous dites quand
même vous vous allez dans ce sens là
quand même vous dites on parle on parle
des Trois Mousquetaires même si le
fantasme on parle de tout on parle de
tout quand même on se rend compte que
tout ce qui raconte après même parfois
le tordant
on le fantasmant en prenant des
métaphores il a quand même tout pris
dans cette époque où il s'appelait déjà
qui c'est ça qui sort terriblement de
votre livre
donné il dira je vais arrêter le tour de
chant parce que
j'ai Amsterdam je termine
donc toutes les chansons parlent de la
Belgique et maintenant j'arrête le tour
de champ parce que je n'ai plus rien à
dire parce que la source de ses chansons
c'est l'enfant et qui ces chansons il
les a développés je dirais presque de
manière continue donc par exemple
prenons la mort ben ou l'attente
l'attente il va y avoir des chansons
comme Zangra il va y avoir des chansons
comme Madeleine on peut regrouper ses
chansons sur des thèmes et donc il va
tordre il va aller plus loin il va
resserrer il va écrire autrement mais il
dira la même chose je vous interrompu
non je vous taquinais parce que
Amsterdam n'est pas en Belgique jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
et donc c'est pourquoi parce qu'en fait
il voulait écrire une chanson sur un
port
quand on écrit une surtout quand on
écrit une chanson un peu moins quand il
s'agit d'un poème mais l'oralité est
essentielle et alors il s'est dit je
vais donc prendre un port belge ok alors
il s'est dit c'est dans une interview
tout ça c'est pas la m'écouter mais je
veux dire que le retrouver alors on ne
peut pas dire dans le port de Zeebrugge
c'est très difficile à chanter dans le
port de Zeebruges il y a des marais
alors que Amsterdam et comme dit Brel
maintenant tout le monde pense que
Amsterdam s'est en Belgique mais j'ai
choisi Amsterdam pour l'oralité des
choses il y a cette photo
ça se met facilement dans la bouche la
langue française est difficile en
chanson j'ai cette photo oui Jacques
Brel ne se marie pas là sur cette photo
bon alors quand même je suis obligé de
parler du mariage parce que
il pose avec une mariée qui n'est pas la
sienne mais dites-nous qui c'est
d'ailleurs mais je vais vous le dire
merci
donc en fait mon père jeune homme de
bonne famille la fleur à la boutonnière
pose pour l'album de famille aux
mariages de son frère il s'agit de ça
belle-sœur Marie-Jeanne mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que Marie-Jeanne et
Pierre sont mariés pierre le frère est
né de mon père
ils vont faire un voyage de noces avec
la voiture du père plus la moustache ils
vont faire un voyage de noces et pour ce
voyage de noces mon père va les
accompagner ainsi que ma grand-mère et
ce premier voyage de mon père en France
va être déterminant et j'en parle dans
mon livre Jacky à ce moment-là au cours
de ce voyage qui est le voyage de noces
de son frère ils vont faire tout un tour
de France en une dizaine de jours et
Jacques va découvrir la liberté grâce à
sa belle-sœur alors vous me dites garçon
de bonne famille avec un mariage tout à
fait classique mais alors il avait une
vision quand même particulière un
mariage
bien sûr mais je suis obligé de me
projeter
France oui la vision de votre père qui
avait votre père du mariage c'est quand
même tout à fait étonnant surtout à
l'époque enfin je sais pas d'ailleurs si
aujourd'hui ce serait possible mais il a
été marié à votre mère il avait des
d'autres femmes et d'autres femmes et
votre mère le savez l'accepter alors
vous empiétez un peu sur le volume que
je suis en train d'écrire je suis désolé
mais vous me donnez nous donner
d'ailleurs dans ce dans ce livre Jackie
cette photo de Jacques Brel mais en
arrière je suis bien obligé de moi je
vais vous ramener vous évoquez on
commence à parler de miche donc mis chez
c'est la maman c'est la maman de France
la maman de toutes les deux tous les
enfants de toutes les filles de Jacques
et Franck
et vous l'évoquez à travers un souvenir
sensuel puisque au moment de la
Libération en 44 45 de la Belgique
raconter et c'est donc c'est un soldat
qui est libère la Belgique qui va
embrasser votre mère et vous raconter ça
c'est pas un hasard parce que c'est
Frida votre mère mais non alors je
voulais maintenant c'est pas Frida alors
il faut que je vous laisse quelque chose
Bertrand c'est qu'en fait
ma Frida je me disais bon Frida comme
Amsterdam ça claque bien voilà c'est ma
toujours dans cette chanson pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas forcément Jacques
Brel écoutez-la ces gens-là avec la
nostalgie
j'ai le témoignage de quelqu'un qui
était dans la bande de copains de mon
père sur la commune d'Anderlecht où il
habite à ce moment-là qui nous a fait un
témoignage
incroyable sur l'existence de Frida dont
tout le monde était amoureux donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle je me permets et
j'en parle dans le livre de cette Frida
c'est une bande de copains d'Anderlecht
et il y a Frida qui est belle comme un
soleil paraît-il et qui est tellement
belle qu'elle est un peu mannequin et
tout ça donc c'est Frida a existé vous
m'auriez posé la question il y a deux
ans j'aurais dit je n'en sais rien
faut pas expliquer les choses parce que
ça casse les fantasmes
il faut que vous me racontiez la vision
de votre père du mariage et alors vous
me dites qui viennent d'une famille de
bonne famille alors comment il a pu
avoir cette éducation et sa vision du
mariage nous sommes bien d'accord que je
suis minoritaire ici en tant que femme
et je vais sans doute vous étonnez la
vision de mon père du mariage ne tient
pas à Jacques mais tiens à ma mère je
vais plus loin
je suis donc en train d'écrire le moment
où mes parents se rencontrent et se
fiancent et dès le début de la relation
j'ai une merveilleuse lettre de ma mère
qui s'adresse à mon père
qui a décidé de refaire un voyage avec
des copains alors que il aurait
peut-être mieux valu qu'il fasse un
petit voyage de qu'importe et ma mère
écrit une lettre extraordinaire à mon
père donc ils sont pas mariés en disant
il faut que tu saches je ne veux jamais
être un boulet pour toi tout ce qui
m'importe c'est de te connaître d'être
près de toi et je m'effacerai toujours
et en bas de ça qu'est-ce que vous dites
c'est pas très féministe déjà vous nous
dites qu'il y a deux ans face à vous et
vous finissez là dessus
nous sommes en direct et nous parlons de
Jacky c'est ce livre formidable avec
plein de photos des photos d'enfants et
pas que et de la famille de Jacques Brel
au début du siècle finalement avec des
extraits vous allez tout savoir c'est
super intéressant j'ai beaucoup aimé si
vous aimez Jacques Brel évidemment vous
êtes fan et vous allez trouver ça dans
toutes les bonnes librairies France
d'où vous vient ce besoin de dire les
choses sur sur votre père c'est faire
vivre la mémoire mais c'est dire une
vérité est-ce qu'il vous appartient
encore votre père d'une certaine manière
personne n'appartient à personne non
mais vous voyez vous dites tout le monde
dit mon papa mon père vous m'ont déjà
vous dites Jacques et Brel mais il est
passé finalement dans le domaine public
le père et vous vous le faites vivre
comme ça est-ce que vous arrivez à avoir
encore du finalement
vous rapprocher de lui et le voir encore
comme votre papa quoi absolument
quand j'étais petite dans cette marmite
donc ça me pose aucun problème mais je
comprends très bien que on puisse on
puisse s'interroger pourquoi je fais
tout ça j'ai voulu dire
parce que exactement comme vous un jour
je vais mourir et
je serai vraiment très triste de mourir
non pas parce que je meurs mais de
mourir en me disant tout ce que j'ai
dans la tête tout ce que je pourrais
éventuellement raconter j'ai vraiment
envie de le transmettre depuis que j'ai
créé la Fondation brève en 81 il y a
plus de 40 ans je fais un métier de
transmission et je pense qu'il est
important après avoir beaucoup lu sur
mon père ah j'ai vu des émissions j'ai
vu des tas de choses j'ai entendu des
tas de choses je me suis dit j'ai juste
envie de mettre les choses à plat vous
comprenez bien que il s'agit pas d'un
règlement de compte plus de 40 ans après
mais plutôt de se laisser porter par un
mouvement de l'histoire et de se dire
mais plus tard quand on se demandera
mais c'était qui Brel de se dire au
moins il y a des éléments qui peuvent
peut-être intéresser parce que ce dont
ce que j'écris là de 1909 à 1947 dans
tous les bons ouvrages la biographie de
mon père ça fait maximum 20 pages j'en
fais 330
et donc je donne des éléments pour mieux
comprendre et c'est ça que j'ai envie de
faire alors encore une fois il y a pas
d'éditeur nous sommes notre propre
éditeur donc dans trois ans on sera pas
en rupture de stock on va pas se
demander si on va réditer je fais ça
pour du long terme pour longtemps après
Bertrand avant oui il faut peut-être
toi tu montres ça c'est donc il y a un
moment donc la Fondation Brel on a la
même caméra
je ne sais pas la Fondation Burel donc
Edith d'excellents livres comme celui
donc comme Jacquie
un travail d'histoire
et biographie une biographie et puis des
travaux je dirais didactique comme là
c'est un recueil de de
du chanteur il y a sur le sur l'auteur
donc c'est quand même des très beaux
livres qui sont toujours très bien
illustrés c'est pour ça qu'on a voulu
aujourd'hui recevoir France et puis
aussi c'est
c'est formidable la Fondation puisque
c'est juste à côté de la Grand-Place à
Bruxelles et là dedans vous on peut
retrouver quelques artefacts tout à fait
extraordinaires de Brel
et puis des enregistrements
parler un tout petit peu de cette
fondation je dirais physiquement mais
physiquement c'est très simple on est
ouvert 7 jours sur 7 et on accueille du
public et le public a le choix entre
différents activités une promenade dans
Bruxelles avec Brel avec un odogué des
chansons tout un parcours et
l'exposition
normalement si on a envie de tout voir
dans notre exposition c'est 16 heures
mais il y a très peu de gens qui
s'installent pour la nuit avec le sac de
couchage et donc les gens reviennent le
nombre de personnes qui reviennent chez
nous et puis le cinéma combien de
personnes viennent par exemple visiter
en moyenne on va dire je sais pas 10 000
visiteurs par an dans des tout petits
locaux on n'est pas subventionnés c'est
vraiment un rêve que j'ai à peu près 300
par 200 300 par jour
et voilà et ça tourne et les gens
viennent et c'est les adieu à Olympia
dans le cinéma et tout ça il y a il y a
un mouvement il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotions il y a des très très beaux
témoignages donc c'est ça la Fondation
mais pour moi l'autre côté de la
Fondation c'est réalisé des films c'est
raconter une histoire c'est de montrer
toutes les archives on a des kilomètres
d'archives j'allais pas à me mettre dans
la tombe sans exploiter tout ça le
public a le droit de savoir toutes ces
choses de connaître ces interviews il y
a des tas de questions que je suis un
grand fan de Jacques Brel on a beaucoup
parlé avec Bertrand Converter allez on
peut faire cette émission j'ai dit
d'accord parce que j'en avais très envie
et je me suis toujours dit tiens quelle
question je pourrais lui poser à lui bon
il n'est pas là donc je vais vous les
poser à vous on s'éloigne peut-être un
peu du livre il penserait quoi de
l'époque aujourd'hui parce que c'est un
homme d'une autre époque moi j'ai
beaucoup entendu écouter ces interviews
ses chansons déjà dans les années 60-70
quand il y a un mouvement de libération
alors lui il est presque un peu ringard
à l'époque il a une vision bon très
classique traditionnelle il pensait moi
aujourd'hui de cette époque selon vous
je pense qu'il irait encore plus loin
que les îles Marquises
je pense que
il serait il serait
il serait affligé de situation qu'ils
verraient certainement est-ce que vous
savez vous imaginez ce qu'il aurait pu
voter aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il votait
déjà à l'époque et ce qu'il pourrait
voter aujourd'hui
mais alors quelle tendance de quelle
tendance il est à l'époque et qu'elle
est-ce qu'il aurait évolué avec son
temps
ce qu'il aurait évolu est-ce que vous
saviez déjà par exemple pour qui voter
quel bord politique qui votait oui bah
alors il était il était un homme de
gauche c'est certain c'est un homme de
gauche il avait d'ailleurs de manière
tout à fait incroyable alors qu'il était
belge qui savait très bien qu'il pouvait
pas soutenir cet homme politique
français qui était évidemment au moment
où je vais le dire maintenant qui
m'échappe ma des Français et donc il
avait un peu soutenu parce qu'il avait
donné un gala pour Mendès France à
Grenoble j'avais rencontré cet homme
qu'il avait trouvé tout à fait
extraordinaire Brel il aime les hommes
il aime les héros il aime les hommes qui
font des choses
mais ça pouvait être un homme politique
comme un aviateur comme Saint-Exupéry
comme un gars qui a un rêve complètement
fou et qu'il le fait type qui a envie
d'apprendre à piloter en hélicoptère il
aime les hommes il aime les hommes qui
concrétisent leurs rêves il aime les
hommes comme lui alors moi je ne sais
pas quel entre guillemets héros l'aurait
fait rêver aujourd'hui je n'en sais rien
nous disiez qu'il était plutôt de gauche
parce que je me souviens de cette
interview par exemple il dit on est dans
les années 70 il y avait 68 qui est
c'est l'air du temps il dit oui l'homme
est un nomade et la femme attend qu'on
vienne lui pondre un œuf c'est quand
même pas très progressiste tout ça je
peux lui répondre
Brassens Brassens qui était son grand
ami et ben voilà il se trouve que au
même moment que vous avez on a des
grands des grands génies de la chanson
des il était pas non plus de 68 heures
au sens bien sûr moi quand je l'écoute
je me permets de prendre la parole mais
quand je l'écoute je vois que
effectivement
maintenant il y a les enfants les petits
enfants et bientôt les arrières
petits-enfants qui l'aiment et que au
fond on peut l'interpréter il était il
était c'était un homme libre surtout
vous en pensez quoi je suis tout à fait
d'accord mais ce que vous ne savez pas
c'est que pour pour mes 68 Jacques a un
petit peu manifesté et je sais qu'il y
avait un mouvement et notamment dans le
film de Lelouch il y a cette séquence où
il y a un congrès pour la libérer les
Assions des prostituées parce que
justement le principe du film c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas d'idées politiques et
que il se trouve quand tu es rentré à la
maison à ce moment-là était vivait ça il
était très engagé en disant et donc là
tout d'un coup mon père avec un discours
pour
améliorer les conditions des prostituées
donc il était dedans il était dedans
mais
alors c'est vrai vous vous dites cette
citation disant voilà mais l'homme se
fait avoir par les femmes qui veulent
pondre un œuf toutes les femmes du monde
veulent que on leur ponde un œuf ce qui
est normal alors l'homme je dis pas
qu'il est bête je dis il paraît
il est con quoi alors il construit une
maison pour protéger le fait tout ça
c'est
c'est un point de vue qui n'empêche
absolument pas à mon père de se dire
chacun fait comme il veut mais il faut
pas oublier que mon père est un homme de
l'oralité il aime les formules et quand
il voit qu'il y a une formule qui
fonctionne bien il va la répéter mais ce
qu'il croit lui-même à ce qu'il vient de
dire ça je n'en suis pas sûr ah ça c'est
intéressant je trouve aussi merci
beaucoup framboises vous avez un dernier
mot Bertrand
il dit qu'il aime les bonbons et il
aimait beaucoup les fleurs on le voit
sur
c'est quand même si on parle de Brel
aujourd'hui c'est que c'était un
formidable chanteur un formidable
interprète mais effectivement quand même
un poète moderne ça peut être moderne et
si aujourd'hui les jeux même les je sais
pas si vous avez écouté récemment une
reprise d'Oxmo Puccino d'une chanson de
Brel et qui mais tout à fait étonnant
tout à fait étonnant c'est quand même il
arrive et dans ces cas ils sont
respectueux les rappeurs c'est à dire
qu'ils gardent le truc merci beaucoup
framboise d'être venu sur notre plateau
enfin que disent dans notre notre salon
Bertrand je rappelle donc Jacky on le
trouve partout on peut le commander
aussi sur la formation
bon et puis vous avez je vous les montre
plein de photos dedans si vous nous avez
rejoint sur la fin de ce live de la
famille de Jacques Brel puisqu'on parle
avant tout de l'enfance du du chanteur
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu de
Belgique Bertrand une prochaine vous
avez pas chanter je suis un peu déçu
de chanter après bref c'est quoi votre
chanson préférée
il faut choisir
les prénoms de Paris et vous France les
fenêtres d'un écoute ça évidemment on
écoutera ça vous retrouvez ça évidemment
sur Youtube c'est très facile merci de
nous avoir suivi alors la suite du
programme sur le figarolive dans
quelques instants dans une dizaine de
minutes oui à 20h le club culture avec
Jean-Christophe buisson c'est une
émission consacrée OBD et puis surtout
vous restez avec nous parce que vers
21h15 21h20 dès qu'une interview
d'Emmanuel Macron sur France 2 se
termine on le débrief ici en plateau
c'est Vincent roseron qui sera là pour
vous accompagner vous avez compris qu'il
faut rester avec nous parce que la
soirée est chargée sur le figure live
merci de nous avoir suivi et bonne
soirée